whiplash on this playoff roller coaster
for the bears let's take you through
what it's been like they were 5-1 out of
the gate this year october 18th they had
nearly an 80 chance at that point it
looked like of making the playoffs then
nearly two entire calendar months of
losing six straight losses for the bears
that brought you into december they were
in single their playoff chances were on
life support in early december then they
get those two wins they knocked out
knockoff houston and minnesota it puts
them back in the playoff picture and
things have changed in a big way in the
last 48 hours check this out last night
arizona losing to san fran that alone
put chicago over 50 their playoff
chances it opened the door if they could
take care of business against
jacksonville today which you just showed
us they did so now the bears with a 70
percent chance
steve kornacki talking about the uh
percentages and the possibilities and
the probabilities as the playoffs
approach week 16 almost completely in
the books a little sunday surprise draft
and because chris i am still feeling
somewhat charitable not much though
since it was christmas three days ago my
gift to you is the first pick oh i just
get the first pick today okay great i'll
take it it's fine it's my gift to you no
because a trivia question was not gifted
to me oh it was not i think there's one
there in the sheets i just don't think
you can read it it's not it's not it's
it's not it's not and trust me it's not
a question go ahead make a pick all
right i guess it's okay it's casey and i
trading insults go ahead um
all right well i don't care i'm gonna go
to saturday you know the saturday
scrimmage that we watched all right i'm
going to talk about that real quick not
that that was a huge surprise but the
fact that we saw a scrimmage in saturday
football where we saw one professional
team and one practice squad team out
there
versus tom brady in the bucks that was
unbelievable you know i just
brady again that offense like we've
talked about the last you know two or
three weeks i mean i don't know the
bucks the way they're playing i think
they're damn scary i think they have
figured it out on the offensive side of
the ball i knew they were going to win
that game yesterday or saturday we both
knew that
but
i mean they could have scored 150 points
in that game if they wanted brady could
have thrown for 700 yards i mean that
was not even a they didn't even need to
break a sweat he was just phenomenal i
felt like talking about it that's why
i'm picking it number one the way he
threw the football the way their offense
looked
they are damn dangerous i mean almost
600 yards of total offense and brady
didn't even play the second half pretty
impressive and i just still think that
was surprising because the lions have at
least competed here the last few weeks
and they totally laid an egg last
saturday
yeah they were down to like the interim
to the interim to the interim coach they
had multiple coaches not available to
covet 19 protocols they tried to get the
game delayed by a day one thing we've
learned since october the nfl is not
going to push games back because they're
concerned it's going to get worse and
you're not going to be able to play it
the next day it's on you to make sure
that your guys are able to go and if
there's any hint that there's any fault
or culpability by players coaches
whatever in a covet 19 outbreak they're
even less likely to
find any type of of lenience or
concession for a team that would like to
get some more time so it's ready to go
so that's what happened to lions and
frankly chris
i i thought that
bruce arians would let tom brady go for
the single game passing record of 554
yards set in 1951 by norman brockman he
had 348 brady did at halftime he only
needed only he only needed 207 to break
it in the second half and only well it's
against the lions jv team
with jv coaching i mean he would have
gotten it if they'd have left him in but
if he would have gotten injured then uh
they probably would have not allowed
bruce aryans to go back to tampa bay
ever again even to go pack up the stuff
at his house first one for me
um i'm gonna stay with saturday
and i i want i want to focus on the
thing that surprised me most about what
happened with the raiders dolphins game
and yeah it was the throw with the the
the head getting ripped off but this i'm
really going to focus in on
the raiders not scoring a touchdown when
they could it's one thing to take that
knee when you're leading late and you're
trying to milk the clock and you've
worked out the the the analytics side of
it as to keeping the other team from
ever having a chance to get the ball
back and on side kick and coming back
and winning
you're up by
well you're not even up at that point
you're down a point
you're trying to work the angle here
to not score
take time off the clock kick a field
goal
and then make it easier for the team to
beat you when they get the ball back
because you're not defending the end
zone at that point you're just trying to
defend
a field goal
i don't know why you don't take the
touchdown look i got no problem with
josh jacobs taking the knee at the one
but then after that when you milk it
down to 105 i think you take the
touchdown with 105. uh the dolphins were
trying to let them score the raiders
didn't want to score
and obviously the result proved that it
was a mistake but i still think
i would rather with the team that has no
timeouts i'd rather give them a minute
on the clock
and say try to score a touchdown then
give them 20 seconds and all i need is
one fluke play
and they're in range for a field goal to
beat me with today's field goal kickers
i always am going to choose to defend
the end zone over defending a field goal
i get that i i do i mean i i i don't
want us to be too you know nitpicky
about it either though you know to too i
mean
i'm with you i would always err on i'd
rather make the team go score a
touchdown definitely but i can
understand gruden's thinking there you
know their defense stinks and it has it
had stunk that whole fourth quarter i
mean so i think that's what he was
scared too i think he was scared because
he just you know on a drive before had
watched the running back catch a
four-yard throw on a slant route and
seven of his guys couldn't tackle him
and miles gaskin ran for a 53-yard
touchdown so i think he was a little bit
like i don't trust my defense here at
the stretch down the stretch i think
ryan fitzpatrick and then will probably
go down and score a touchdown so
like i'm with you but i'm not going to
sit here and get mad at gruden for that
i am going to get mad at damon arnett
the corner over there who's in cover 2
and he's protecting the flat
like a four-yard gain into the flats
going to change the game no you get back
did he call that defense no call that
defense no but i'm sure don't be mad at
him
he's been coached on what to do i mean
he's supposed to not go to the flat in
that scenario i know that i played in
the defense i played in tampa during the
tampa 2 era that was a mess up but
either way i get you uh and it's it's
certainly a a good talking point um
i'm gonna go to the third quarter
explosion by the sea the pittsburgh
steelers i think that's probably one of
the shockers of the of sunday to me just
because
the way the steelers had looked on
offense the last few weeks the way they
had looked through the first two
quarters of the game yesterday i just we
were getting to that where he just went
chalk it up i mean the steelers are done
they're done
like they're not go i mean we're sitting
there going man they looked so bad
that yes cleveland was down to the jets
at that time but you went i think
cleveland's going to win the game still
and pittsburgh is going to lose and
cleveland's going to beat pittsburgh
next week and pittsburgh is going to end
up on the road you know in their first
round wild card game i mean that's
really where i had my brain had gone and
then the big pass of deontay johnson and
here we go and they got the mojo going
and big ben started throwing that
football around the field and mike the
big thing is what we've talked about the
last two or three weeks too
they look at their touchdowns deontay
johnson down the sideline juju smith
schuster down the middle for you know
his 25-yard touchdown pass they kept
blockers in they made big ben feel good
okay i'm comfortable i'm protected and
now i can throw the ball down the field
and to me with the older quarterbacks
that's something that you gotta tinker
with and brady and the bucks have
figured that out
next one for me the fact that the
falcons played the chief so close 1714
who would have ever dreamed that final
score for chiefs falcons we had 37 30.
that was my pick as of wednesday and i'm
glad
i changed my mind after hearing you
explain it during our mega pix podcast
that the falcons would cover they did
cover but to only have
31 total points in the game and to have
the game as close as it was that was a
stunner to me because i thought the
chiefs were kind of past that i thought
they'd learned that they do kind of
sleepwalk from time to time and they
weren't going to let it happen they let
it happen they still found a way to win
barely but i was surprised it was as
close as it was yeah i you know i
thought that atlanta might be able to
keep it close you know sun shines on a
dog's butt every now and then during the
pick segment and that one was where i i
ended up right but i think the thing
that's concerning you know the falcons
have been playing good d we've seen the
falcons be able to rush the quarterback
and the chiefs are having issues
protecting the quarterback right now
that's that's a real issue i i haven't
seen them like this through the mahomes
andy reid era so you know hopefully they
can get healthy here down the stretch
and change that little aspect
of their football team but um yeah they
were in danger of losing all together
which was was a little surprising to me
um i think my next one is going to have
to be
andy dalton and the high flying cowboys
just for what they did in the past game
their wide receivers everything not that
i'm shocked that they won against the
philadelphia eagles but i didn't think
they were going to score 37 points and
andy dalton was going to throw for
almost 400 yards and just carve them up
that way that was pretty surprising and
now i give them the lead leader and
they're in the leader house to win the
nfc east
well and ezekiel elliott also that was
my surprise the fact that he had that
rebirth at a time when people were
saying hey maybe tony pollard is a
better option at tailback for the
cowboys for me the jets two-game winning
streak i'm surprised that's still on the
board j-e-t-s jets jets jets they had
the video of firemen ed on the board
yesterday at the empty metlife stadium
here they are two wins in a row maybe if
they can finish with three in a row adam
gase is back next year is
okay it's a testament to the fact that
it's the nfl there's pride and sometimes
sometimes guys can find a way when you
think there's no way and sorry jets fans
but no trevor lawrence maybe justin
fields maybe someone else maybe sam
darnold is your guy next year maybe all
to be determined as the off season
unfolds
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports